So let's take a look at the code
for the set announcement servlet. You'll need to
have imported the memcache service and the memcache
service factory. Obviously import all the things you
need for attp servlet, and you'll have to
import the conference and the constants. The set
announcement servlet extends http servlet, and then basically
we write the logic to find out the conferences
that are nearly sold out. So this is just a query. So we do the ofy.load. We're
loading entities of kind conference. We're filtering first on
seats available less than five, but there's no point
in telling us about conferences that have no
seats left at all. So obviously we need to
filter on seat available at least one, ie, which
is greater than, greater than zero. And then we
create an array, and basically just add each of the
conference names to the array. And then, if we do have
some conferences, we're going to build a string that we're going to
use as the announcement. We get the announcement key, which is
stored in the Constants file. Obviously, we have to get
the Memcache service, so we use the MemcacheServiceFactory to get the
Memcache Service. We use announcement key, and we save our announcement in
Memcache. We set the status of the response to 204.